Guys, welcome to this little impromptu live that I'm running.
I didn't plan on doing this, but I wanted to share a couple things.
So I didn't make any kind of an announcement in terms of me going live or anything like
that.
Okay.
So what I wanted to share really, really quick, by the way, it's December 2nd.
We have takeout Christmas and New Year's Eve and Christmas Eve.
We have like three, a little over three weeks of working time left in this year.
And you know, a lot of people in this group, a lot of people in business in general, a
lot of our clients are a lot of people that we want to work with or potentially work with.
They might be just like taking their foot off the gas.
And so this is a time where you can either take your foot off the gas, which if that's
what you choose to do, that's completely fine.
I used to be so frustrated when I would think about people doing this.
But this business, we do this business so that we can choose the kind of life and lifestyle
that we want.
So I have no problems with that if that's what you choose to do.
But for some of us, like myself, I'm trying to put my foot on the gas.
I'm trying to go as fast as possible to the very, very end so that I start the year now.
Okay.
So let me go ahead.
I want to tag everyone real quick.
Let's go like this.
Come quick.
That's what I said.
So I just barely got done this morning.
I woke up.
One of the things I wanted to do that was on my priorities this week and as like one
of my to-do's this week that I needed to get done is I wanted to go and review my goals,
my 2024 goals.
Now, the first thing, the first problem with this and what I just said is the fact that
I needed to go and review, which means that it's been a long time since I've done this.
And I'm going to be completely transparent with you guys.
I think it was, man, at the beginning of this year, I was, make sure you're checking your
goals every once in the morning, once at night.
I think we had Zach Powell on, I think it was like when I was in Africa about the spring
or something like that.
And he was talking about checking your goals every six hours.
And I love that.
I love that idea of that.
And I did it for a while.
And then I got off path and I got off track and I got distracted.
And anyway, today, it's kind of like, I don't know if you guys have ever been in a position
where you know that your bank account isn't great and you like avoid looking at it, even
though you know what's in it.
You don't want to look at it.
I remember back in 2019, 2018, I hated logging into my account because it just kind of highlighted
the fact that I was in such a bad situation.
And then once I got in there, it was manageable, but it was always like I was trying to avoid
it.
So anyway, today I knew I was like, I got to get down, I got to look at my goals, see
where I'm at, see how I can course correct, et cetera.
And that's what I did.
So a couple of things that I learned while going through those, and the reason I want
to come and talk about this now is everybody waits until the first of the year to set their
goals.
And then the irony is we set the goals on December 25th, September 26, between Christmas
and New Year's.
And then everybody goes out on New Year's Eve, they get completely drunk, smashed, and
they start the year with a hangover, right?
And that's, it's crazy.
And by the weekend, no one's going to the gym, no one's doing anything, no one's making
their calls, no one's doing their due diligence, no one's doing any of this stuff.
So what I want to do before the beginning of the year comes, I want to get my goals
in place right now and start working towards them now.
So I have a jumpstart in everybody else.
But a couple of things that I learned and I encourage you guys to go look at the goals
that you set early 2024 and just review them.
And it hopefully some of you guys had a phenomenal year.
Hopefully some of you guys like really, really crushed it and you stuck to your goals.
And the disappointing part, guys, at least for me with looking at my goals.
And there was a couple that I hit for sure.
And there was a couple. The ones that I hit were not even ones that I was really that
excited about or expecting to hit, but with a change of fate and a twist of destiny,
I guess, I decided to pick up my slack in some of these areas.
But the crazy part is what I started realizing as I was going through my goals is that at
the beginning of the year, 2024, I set my goal and then I created the map.
Just like when you guys join this group, right?
You you create you set your goal.
And then if you watch exhaustive and satisfied, you go through and it shows you
exactly how to create your map to get to the goal.
And you do this for every single one of your goals.
It doesn't matter if it's a fitness goal, doesn't matter if it's a spiritual goal.
It doesn't matter if it's a relationship goal.
It doesn't matter if it's a business goal.
It's the same formula.
You break it down into quarters and then in the months and then in the weeks, then in
the days and then sometimes in the hours.
And you go and you attack it.
And once you set the goal, all you have to do and you set the goal, you set the map,
you set like your exact roadmap to get there.
All you have to go is it all you have to go and do is just do exactly what's on the
map. You just have to follow the map.
If it says that on Tuesday, December or whatever, you need to do five cold calls or
you need to talk to five business owners, that's what you have to do, even if you
don't feel like it. Right.
Just like the example I always use, if you're in, you know, New York and you want to
get to Los Angeles, you got a map and you know exactly how to get there by.
January 4th, you know how many miles you need to you need to travel, you know which
states you need to go through, you know where you can stop, where your breaks for
the bathroom, where your breaks to eat, to sleep, et cetera.
You have this entire map laid out and all you got to do is do the map.
But the problem is we get distracted.
The problem is we get tired.
The problem is we get, you know, oh, let me go do this.
Let me check out this. Let me go to this state.
Look at this. And that's equivalent to us in this business like, oh, I'm going to
start this thing. I'm going to go and do this.
I'm going to do that. That trip that's going to come before hitting my goals.
So to me, I sat there today and I was like, I set all these goals at the beginning of
the year. The year passed.
This is the part that's like really, really kind of a slap in the face, guys, is
that the year passed, right?
Eleven months has passed since we set these goals, almost 12 months.
And there's somebody out there that created a million dollars for themselves, a
new million dollars.
There's somebody out there that became a millionaire this year.
There's somebody out there that probably for sure that became a billionaire.
There's somebody out there that got the body that they have been waiting their
whole lives to get. There's somebody out there that created the relationship that
they've waited their entire lives to create.
And then there's some of us or some of you.
And I would speak for us in general that like we were in the same spot we were
last year. Right.
And it's weird because even if you improve incrementally.
The improvement from last year to this year feels better than staying the same as
last year, even if even if your last year was better than than my last year, for
example. And I remember this because me going from eight to ten thousand dollars
a month, negative sixty thousand dollars in debt to making my first million
dollars. That was the best thing ever.
Right. That was the best thing ever because I increased.
I did. Now, from twenty twenty to twenty twenty one, we made more money on a
gross level, but I spent more money as well.
And I didn't really make much more money in my pocket.
So for twenty twenty to twenty twenty one, I made almost half a million dollars
more. I made one point four or five something million dollars, one point four or
five one. And by the way, this is not the course.
This is just with lead generation.
I made almost a half a million dollars more than I did in twenty twenty.
But I put the almost the exact same amount in my pocket.
And I wasn't near as excited at all about that because I didn't really improve.
But going from twenty nineteen from eight to ten thousand dollars a month, barely
making it to getting to a million dollars was phenomenal.
Right. Because I improved.
So anyway, all this to say, guys, what I encourage you guys to do before it becomes
the first of the year becomes Christmas and we've got like four days, five days and
everyone's, you know, cold and drinking spiked eggnog.
Why don't we spend time right now, early December, spend time this week reviewing
your goals. Look at where you messed up.
Where did you get off track? What was it that happened?
What what derailed you?
What at what point did you decide to take a different route than the route that was
going to get you to the Los Angeles or the Miami, which is your ultimate goal?
Because all you would have had to do, this is me speaking to myself, is follow the
freaking map, Nick, and you could have been to that goal.
You could have done this thing.
Guys, there was things I was so excited about that I completely got derailed.
And I used personal issues in my life.
Oh, but I'm dealing with this.
Oh, but I got this relationship thing.
Oh, but I got this family thing.
Oh, but I'm here. I'm there.
This, that and the rest.
This happened. Yeah, guys, I got things happen, man.
I had some stuff that I had to take care of, some like legal stuff that was
complete, I think, complete BS.
It's completely handled.
It was it was it was basically a competitor that went and found a loophole.
And anyway, long story short, we dealt with that all year and last year.
And at times when I wasn't, you know, making that progress to my towards my goals,
I was using that.
Some of you guys have a sick pair.
Some of you guys are in the middle of a divorce.
Some of you guys have custody issues.
We all have stuff.
And it's just like when you take a road trip, everyone has car issues.
Everyone has the flat tire.
Everyone has this thing.
And you have to just realize those things are going to come.
But you got to stay on track.
And if those things come, you got to make up for it.
So, my friends, one thing that I was just going to throw out there,
one thing that I'm thinking about this year is as I'm writing down my goals
and I'm writing down my goals in four different categories,
we're going to have probably an entire live on goal setting
because I think it's super, super important.
I know it can become mundane and whatever.
But it's very, very important to write it down and to keep reviewing it.
One of the things I started thinking today as I was writing down my goals,
I was looking at last year's goals.
I'm like, how do I want to take any of those and bring them into this year?
Do I want to start completely fresh?
And I started thinking, you know, a couple of years ago,
when we talked about goals, I would talk to people about the the goal
and then the die goal or the junkie goal, the goal.
That's like, hey, if I don't hit this, I'm going to do something crazy.
I'm going to I'm going to put an embarrassing picture of myself on the Internet.
I'm going to give away ten thousand dollars.
I'm going to do something very, very crazy.
I'm going to publicly humiliate myself if it doesn't happen.
And I also call it the junkie goal. Right.
And the analogy with the junkie is that for some reason, the junkie,
the guy on the street, the gal on the street that needs the heroin hit
or whatever in their arm, they always find a way to get the hit.
They always find a way to get the needle in their arm.
They have no money. They have no home. They have no clothes.
They barely are breathing.
Yet somehow, someway, whether it's diving for tin cans
to go collect enough money to get enough to buy the hit, they always find a way.
Maybe it's sometimes it's not great.
Sometimes it's stealing.
Sometimes it's it's doing some very heinous things,
but they always find a way to get the hit.
And it's like we for some reason just treat our stuff so casually.
We need to treat it. We need to become junkies in a way.
And that sounds so weird and it sounds kind of backwards.
But we we should learn from these people, man.
They figure out a way no matter what comes to to to get to their goals.
And so this year, what I want to do, Stephanie, what's going on?
Good to see you, Bruce. What's going on, Richard?
Of course, this year, what I want to do is I'm setting die goals.
I'm setting junkie goals.
I'm setting goals of like I'm willing.
The goals that I'm going to set this year are goals that I'm willing
to post publicly so that people can hold me accountable,
which means I'm going to think about it a couple of times
before I just throw it on my list of like, yeah, I'm going to do this.
I'm going to run the, you know, the Boston Marathon.
I'm going to qualify for the Boston Marathon.
I'm going to run a sub three, three mile, three hour marathon.
Right. Like, I'm going to think about that before I go and throw that up.
And one thing that I'm really considering and I might ask you guys
to do the same or consider the same is like as you're going through your goals,
you're reviewing last year and you're looking at this year.
What if your goals were public?
What if the things that you're you're writing down were there for everybody
to see and everybody could hold you accountable?
How would you change it? I'm not saying to think smaller.
I'm saying what I'm saying to think very seriously about what you write down
this year. OK, because what I know, guys, is this.
It takes one good year.
It takes one. Put your head in the sand.
Put nothing in the sand.
Put your head down, put your blinders on, get to work.
And guys, in one year, your entire life can change.
One year, I watched it in 2019.
My life was the same. It wasn't 18. It was the same in 17.
It was a little bit better in 17 than it was in 16 because I was broke.
But in 16, it was far worse than it was in 15.
My life didn't change for a long time.
And then guess what? In 2020, I figured it out.
I removed the distractions. I got simple.
I got very basic.
I got Mr. Scrappy McScrappy, where I didn't care about how I looked.
I didn't care about being out with the boys.
I didn't care about playing pickleball, playing golf, being at lunches,
watching Netflix. I was there to make money.
I was so sick and tired of being broke and having a credit card credit card
desk sitting on my desk, looking me in the face that I was like, I'm done.
And within eight months, I was at one hundred thousand dollars per month.
And within 12 months, I was I made my first million dollars,
paid off my debt, was looking at my first rental properties,
looking at it. I think I was in a new house at that point.
My entire life changed.
And more than just the money that I made in that year, guys, was my identity changed.
And one thing that I've realized is that once you get to a certain level in business,
a certain level in income, this is not an analogy that I came up with.
I think it was probably Brian Tracy and then it was probably Jim Rohn.
And then it was probably one of these other gurus.
But they talk about this thermostat that we have, this financial thermostat,
where once we hit a certain level, we become comfortable at that level.
And we can't go below it.
And if we do, the heat kicks on. Right.
It can also work against us, because as we if we have a really good year,
we make a lot of money.
Sometimes negatively, we kick on the AC.
We come back down to where we're comfortable.
But one thing I've learned about about myself and my identity
is that once I made a million dollars, once I became one hundred thousand dollar
per month person, I can never go back.
I will never make less than a million dollars.
I just can't. I just can't.
Like, it's who I am. It's my identity.
I'm not saying that my my entire self worth is tied to it.
But I do not make less than a million dollars.
That is like the that is the the floor.
And I will never go less than a million dollars.
I can't imagine making less than a million dollars.
And I don't say that like one of these weird people
that's trying to act like they're super rich.
I'm not the top of any totem pole.
It's just it's interesting because, guys, if you will just claw your way
to one hundred thousand dollars per month and see what it's like to be at one
hundred thousand, some of you guys are like, that's not very much.
A lot of you guys are like, that's that'd be amazing.
OK, get to one hundred thousand.
See how it feels. Then get to a quarter million.
See what life's like at a quarter million.
You're never going to go below it.
Get to a half a million.
Get to seven hundred and fifty thousand, three quarter million.
Get to a million dollars.
Get to a hundred thousand dollars per month and see what life's like.
You will never want to go back.
OK, it will completely change your identity.
People will start to talk to you differently.
People will start to respect you more.
People will start to take you more seriously.
Doors will be open to you.
People will start reaching out to you to to pick your brain.
Instead of you always reaching out to pick up the people's brain.
By the way, I hate that sentence.
Everything changes.
And what I'm sitting here and trying to speak,
I'm basically just sharing my thoughts out loud because I'm talking to myself
as I'm thinking through this day, is everything can change in a year.
Your entire life can change in a year.
And right now, guys, I feel like I'm in a decent spot.
Financially, I've been in a pretty good spot for a bit,
but I'm not satisfied at all.
In fact, I'm disgusted with the progress that I've made.
If I look at the progress I made from 19 to 20, compared with 23 to 24,
I'm disgusted because it hasn't been much.
It's been incremental.
And yes, it's at a much higher level than it was in 2019 compared to 2020.
But man, I'm just pissing my life away if I'm looking at it.
If I'm being very, very honest, I just made a post about this on Instagram
and Facebook about like this year, I'm going to just level with you guys.
A lot of the decisions I made, I know nothing was crazy,
but like I made a lot of decisions that were very temporary in the moment.
Like I chose, I put this, I chose comfort over calling.
I chose temporary satisfaction.
I chose temporary pleasure over long term satisfaction
in a lot of different areas of my life, in a lot of different moments of my life,
a lot of different months.
Now, it wasn't the entire year, but a lot of the year.
And because of that, I came short on a lot of stuff.
And I'm here being straight, completely honest with you guys.
And again, I even said this on my post.
I am not, this isn't a woe me, this isn't a downer.
I'm super excited.
I hope you guys can feel my energy.
I spent about an hour and 10 minutes today on version 3.0.
And I'm going to spend another hour and a half, hour to hour and a half tomorrow.
Guys, I'm so pumped about 3.0 and what it's going to look like.
Now, I don't want you guys, when's that going to come out?
It's going to be out before the end of quarter one.
I'm making sure this thing is so dialed in.
Now, a lot of the, and we'll get into more of the details there,
but like, I'm so pumped about what we have or what's coming for you guys.
And I'm so pumped about those of you that just started,
because you guys have something at your fingertips that you can go
and you can escape the rat race with this.
Your entire freaking life.
I'm texting one of my buddies right now, who's just about to become a digital landlord.
And he's kind of been on the fence for a while.
I'm super stoked. I hope he watches this video,
because we've been talking for months.
And he's like, I need to do something. I need to do something.
Guys, you have the tool in front of you.
You have the, literally, you have the thing that can get you to whatever you want to do.
And I used to think everyone should become this, you know,
let's get to a million dollars a month, every single person.
That's not for everybody.
But every single person should escape the rat race.
Every single person should be able to live on, you know,
money that comes in from assets that they've built and ranked and rented from this business.
You've paid to be here.
The business works.
It's working for me. It's working for Jason.
It's working for Porter.
It's working for, I just got a message from Drew Wolber, by the way.
And Drew Wolber just barely hit $50,000 per month.
Okay, $50,000 per month.
I don't even know when he started, but it wasn't that long ago.
It was like 18 months ago.
He's at $50,000 per month.
He's trying to be on, he's trying to be on Ryan Dalton's heels.
Okay, guys, your entire life can change in one year.
So what I'm asking you guys to do is before the end of the year comes,
we're going to do some more goal setting.
We'll do another live on goal setting.
Maybe I'll walk you through how I'm going to do mine.
Maybe I'll walk you through mine live.
I don't know.
But what I'm asking you to do is before we get to Christmas,
and there's that little week after Christmas between New Year's,
when we're trying to rush our goals and we spend 30 minutes on them,
take time right now, review.
Look where you came short.
How did you get short?
Where did you get distracted?
What distracted you?
Was it worth it?
I'm sure it wasn't.
Okay, but look at what you traded this year instead of your goals.
Look at what you chose.
Look at the temporary pleasures and distractions you chose this year
instead of achieving your goals.
Because right now, every single one of us could sit here and be like,
I got that one done.
We'd have the biggest smile on our face.
We'd have the most satisfaction ever.
Guys, back to my live on exhausted but satisfied.
That is the thing that you want to chase.
That is the thing that's going to be with you forever,
is those moments when you do hard things that you don't think you can do
and you pull them off and you have the most satisfied freaking feeling in the world.
I'm reading this book right now.
It's about this guy that bought this freaking gold rush town in California.
And he talks about like he's out there working with his hands
and he just bought this entire town for just under a million bucks.
And he's like, I read this line.
I highlighted it last night.
I was reading it as I went to bed.
And he said, I went to bed, my body went to bed exhausted,
but my mind went to bed at peace.
My body went to bed exhausted, but my mind went to bed at peace.
That's how I want to live.
Every single day, I want to be freaking exhausted.
Even if it's mentally, I'm probably not going to be super tired
sitting in my chair every single day building websites, talking on the phone.
I'm not out there working with my hands, but it still is tiring.
And I might be mentally exhausted, but I want to have peace.
When I hit the pillow, I want to know I gave every single thing that I could give
and I move that needle closer.
So I'm basically doing this live for me to go back and look at later
to see where I was at.
But I thought that I'd share it instead of just keeping it within,
instead of just putting it in my journal, which I will do as well.
I wanted you guys to know that today I went through, I reviewed my goals.
I came up big time short, big time short.
Doesn't even make sense.
I came up short, big time.
It wasn't my year.
It wasn't my year at all.
I traded a lot of things I could have achieved and I regret that very, very much.
But you know what?
You can't look at the past.
Whatever.
It's time to move forward.
Instead of waiting until January 1st and just pissing away the rest of here,
I'm ready to start now.
It's December 2nd.
It's cold, baby.
But luckily we work inside so I can wear a cutoff digital landlord's shirt.
But it's cold outside and that doesn't mean I'm not going to be working.
So guys, go and review your goals.
I'm stoked.
We got a live coming tomorrow.
Me and Zach Powell are going live.
We're going to be talking about leverage, how you can leverage yourself
and create a beautiful team that can help you grow.
By the way, you don't need a teaser.
You don't need that many people to create a seven-figure business in this business
and you don't need to pay that much in payroll
because we have things like onlinejobs.ph and all these different tools.
But guys, get on that live.
Zach Powell's making over $50,000 per month.
He's been doing this for a long time as well.
Super solid guy, amazing business owner, amazing entrepreneur,
and I'm super stoked for that.
So 7 a.m. MST for those of you that are on MST.
Otherwise, do your calculations, guys.
I am going to go be with my kids
and then get back in the saddle.
Back in the saddle, baby.
I'm out.
Talk to you guys tomorrow.